alors thierry je vous donne l occasion
de vous venger
ah ah oui car ce soir je vais
transformer en biya jovovich attention
je vous posais des questions syrie était
vous n'êtes pas content vous pouvez me
balancer un verre d'eau d'acteurs
d'accord
les bee gees
ça n'a rien à voir si on pense que tout
ça ça n'a rien à voir
alors attention alors voilà alors vous
avez vous avez vos verres derrière qui
rit je vous pose des questions dès que
vous n'êtes pas content de ma question
pourrait me jeter un verre à la gueule
il ya des petits verres et des grands
mères à sa dépendance il faites vous
plaisir pouvait démarrer par un petit
verre et plus ça ira
l'annoncé des singles tout le monde dit
que vous êtes un grand producteur à
succès les news sur tf1 c'était pas une
réussite un ou deux semaines
ouais enfin j'ai eu l'intelligence
d'arrêter au bout d'une semaine
non là vraiment c'est vous qui avez
arrêté c'est moi qui suis allé voir
mougeotte en dix ans j'arrête le patron
d'air croyais pas n'y croyais pas et le
lundi suivant n'y avait pas d'émission
quand une émission est mal née il faut
pas essayer de la faire continuer voilà
les vingt jours merci pas moi et c'est
une vraie anecdote je devais faire ma
première télé dans l'émission du lundi
suivant
je me fiche de christophe alévêque à
bridget pas de verre d'eau parce que
c'est un c'est plutôt à mon honneur
d'avoir su arrêter avant que ça d une
catastrophe
vous n'avez pas le permis de conduire
c'est parce que boire ou conduire il
faut choisir
oui c'est ça vous avez choisi de donc
voila merci non fumé au conduire à les
choisir j'ai choisi de finir vous avez
la même maquilleuse depuis des années
parce qu'elle a une formation de peintre
en bâtiment
la plus en plus de boulot magnifique non
franchement vous chouchoute robot multi
postale c'est vrai nom sans rigoler mais
j'ai pas eu pourtant complété par une
phrase ce n'est pas là où vous habillés
en noir pour cacher votre cul ouais
franchement faudrait pas honnête est
peut-être pas
hercules le cul ça fait longtemps que je
le dis je dis tout le temps je suis bâti
comme une bouteille de perrier et
d'ailleurs ça fait quelques années que
je fais de la muscu justement pour être
liés comme sa dette juste comme ça
bon ben alors voilà donc vous ne voulez
pas en fait non je n'en veux pas à vous
répondez plutôt merci
non mais arrêtez moi vous êtes vous
recevoir et et nous accueillait
alors que ne pouvait pas ça glisse
beaucoup
faites attention l'essec laisser tirer
je vais débarrasser à manger débarrasser
année et iris je fais tout moi dans le
noir oui est ce qu'aujourd'hui je peux
vous mettre un petit peu de couleurs
intenses politesse à un petit peu alors
non parce que regarder c'est moi je suis
un petit peu pas trop en bâtiment mais
c'est vrai donc si je pouvais vraiment
mettre un petit peu vrai j'ai un petit
peu de peinture c'est rien c'est est-ce
que ça part en transformer un petit peu
en jaune et voir si l'eau chaude vous va
bien un petit peu un petit peu vous me
connaissez pas l'eau
beaucoup trop pâti comme ça juste la
voix soit pas très chic
oui ça y est le petit passe ou
maintenant si je les regarde et je n'ai
pas très bien mais c'est vrai je vous
fournit un très beau copé
bon
mais je veux dire exceptionnelle match
je peux faire un plan trop le voc a
soufflé sur un dérivé neige
exceptionnellement ce soir pouvait voir
dans le marché plus la ville est révélé
j'avais un super bien mais ça nous passe
superbe la freestyle aller voler un
stade où les séries on va terminer cette
émission par le plat intex